It's time to count.
Down to top 100, what ifs we've ever made.
But we can't.
Squeeze all that into one video.
So instead we're going to do it in our first ever.
What if 100 book
Join us as we dive deeper into the 100 most popular?
What if scenarios we've ever explored want to know what a portal to
a parallel universe would look like? Well, turn to page 51.
Want to know what would happen if we dumped our trash into volcanoes,
that's on page one 95,
we're taking everything you love about what if and giving you more of it.
More original artwork that transports you into impossible worlds,
more fun facts to help you understand the science behind those worlds.
More expert information,
including a foreword written by legendary physicist,
Dr. Michio Kaku. And on top of that,
a bonus list of the most ridiculous.
What if questions asked by our fans?
What are you waiting for? Pre-order is available now. And our website shop done.
What if show.com get a digital or a physical copy for your loved one.
Or for yourself? Because.
After all,
having this book on your coffee table is guaranteed to make you look
smart.
So.
Want to know what the most popular, what if ever made was.
Well, that's a story for the, what if book.